[Music]
leah is with us or lee in new york city
is it leah or lee it's leah hi great hi
happy thanksgiving what are you thankful
for
i'm thankful that my family is healthy
and that we are on baby step three yay
how can we help
hi so we have been on a budget for a
while but from time to time we keep
running into this issue of
that we can't wait for the next paycheck
to come it's almost like we're running
out of money and i feel like we're not
doing something right in dividing up the
money or the budget within the month
and also even though we are on baby step
three and we paid off all our debt we
kind of still feel like at this point
that we're almost like living paycheck
to paycheck so to speak what's your
household income
so
um
my husband is working
um he's making 90 40 9 400 take home pay
that's your household income
yes okay
so when you guys were doing a budget
when you were paying off debt was there
margin left over
um
well at the time i was also working it
was remark it was very hard it was it
was it was
so there was a drop in income not much
is that what's causing this to drop an
income from you not working
um i don't think so i mean we did have
another child and i my income wasn't so
great it was i was working only
part-time so and he also received the
raise
in the past few months okay when you
both when you do a budget both of you
sit down and look at what is allocated
to each category and you're both
agreeing to that
correct correct
and then what happens that blows it up
um
the budget is is fine we have money for
every everything and every category it's
just that as we start spending the money
and starting to track the money it's
almost like we run out of the actual
money in the bank before
um well no but the bank money is
reflected on the budget so you're you're
running out of money in the category if
you're overspending you're either
overspending a category or under funding
a category
if you have 9 400 taking that it's just
that let's say our bills are due earlier
than the next paycheck would come in
it's like why would you budget that you
need to budget what's the reality is
your budget's not a mythology template
that just is the way you wish life is
your budget needs to reflect what life
is
and it does no it doesn't
because your bills are coming up in a
budget outside the budget
they're coming to you and they're not in
their budget actual money is not in our
checking account you're saying it's a
timing problem but you need to be
budgeting for whatever that paycheck
coming in you need to make sure that
you've got a plan for that money and
that money needs to be able to cover
your bills
so within the month it's budgeted for
correctly it's just that the money is
not in my checking account yet
and that's what we're saying is don't
budget for money that doesn't exist
if you've got 9400 because we get paid
twice a month
okay so you've got to learn to adjust
the budget into two halves then
the two times a month where you've got a
certain amount coming out
for food
in the first month first half of the
month but you've got a bunch of other
bills hitting so your food budget may be
a little lower in the first half and a
little higher in the back half when you
don't have as many other bills hitting
so you may have to run two half budgets
that are zeroed out to make this work to
get your timing right until you can get
a little bit ahead of
the budget and and have a little bit of
slush in there to be able to make this
run
um
but
i think you guys are watching too much
netflix and not spending enough time on
this budget this is not rocket science
you can sit down and figure this out
when both of you lean into it and sit
down and look at it and push on it and
go every one of these dollars needs a
name and it needs to it needs to reflect
the reality of our month the cable bill
is due on the 25th that has to show up
in this budget the electric bill is due
on the third that has to show up in this
budget we have to see how that's going
to work and just spend a little bit of
time on it planning it out i think you
can do it